how do you remake Resident Evil 4 an
experience that changed the way action
games are made today it is at best an
unfair Challenge and at worst an
impossible task so instead of trying to
reinvent the wheel a second time
developer Capcom has doubled down on the
Brilliance of the original's design
elaborated on it and finally tuned The
Experience so that it reminds long time
fans like me of its Brilliance while
also subverting expectations all the
while introducing an all-new generation
to a modern classic and one of the most
important games of all time
foreign
if you're not familiar the premise of
residential 4 is straightforward Leon
asks Kennedy the cool and handsome
rookie cop turned government agent who
you may remember from his escapades and
Resident Evil 2's raccoon city has been
sent to rural Spain to track down Ashley
Graham the U.S president's missing
daughter yes it is a save the princess
Trope but even 18 years later it's
juxtaposition against the survival
horror genre serves as an Immaculate
setup for the games over-the-top set
pieces in this case the princess is in
another Castle but it's a castle
besieged by parasitic infections and
mind-controlled cultists so you'll have
to blast your way from a rundown Village
to a military Island to get her back
while the core pillars of tense up and
close personal action and careful
Resource Management remain welcomingly
unchanged improvements to character
developments Elevate the experience as a
whole Leon isn't just a cool looking
dude with superhero and a sweet jacket
who says sometimes cool sometimes corny
things and does super cool stuff he's
more than that now he's a cool dude with
cool hair doing cool stuff but who also
acts like a human being this is a leon
who carries the trauma of the Raccoon
City incident from Resident Evil 2
remake which gives more weight to his
character and serves as compelling
context for his motivation to save
Ashley Graham for him this isn't just
another assignment it's a chance at
Redemption for the lives he couldn't
save in Raccoon City those concern this
added layer of humanity has changed
Leon's iconic Action Hero cheesiness
shouldn't worry as Leon is still an
absolute one-liner cornball in fact this
aspect of his character has been churned
up a notch through the chaos of
blood-soaked battles where he faces down
crowds of parasite infected ganandos
Leon still takes the time to toss out
one-liners and it serves as an
incredible way to ease the
nerve-wracking tension of a fight
of course everyone going
bingo the world of Resident Evil 4 is
grimy filth covered and horrific but
it's also one where a government agent
trying to save the president's daughter
also says not bad right to himself after
suplexing a ganado so hard its head pops
like a water balloon facing off against
the ganondo is more stress-inducing and
terrifying than ever before the frenetic
movement's unexpected lurches and
vicious attacks have all been
intensified making each encounter a
panic Waltz of crowd management fighting
for breathing room and hoping you've got
enough Animal Health to get through it
all seeing Dr Salvador the chainsaw
Wheeling potato sack wearing Maniac
stopped through the crowd to try
entirely on a part resurfaced a fear
that repeated playthroughs of
residential 4 had long since dulled
these scenarios are absolutely heart
pounding and despite the hair raise
intention I couldn't get enough of it
because the combat just feels so damn
good from blasting a wall of enemies
with a shotgun to a quick Parry of a
stampeding pitchfork wielding ganondo to
deliver a sweeping roundhouse kick that
pushes back the crowd residential 4
remakes action has a kinetic brutality
that feels like controlling chaos in the
most satisfying way it all feels Punchy
visceral and badass to pull off Leon has
of course been given more versatility to
take on the more capable and deadly
gonados fundamentally the absence of
tank controls means he's much easier to
control In the Heat of battle but now he
has the ability to stealth and has more
options when employing his trusty knife
fighting skills knives now have
durability a carryover from Resident
Evil 2 remake with each use slightly
damaging it knives can now be used to
Parry nearly every attack by hitting a
button just as enemies strike as well as
used to instantly Break Free when being
grabbed these new additions Elevate the
Tango of violence when dealing with a
crowd of enemies by creating a sense of
momentum each fight can quickly become a
dance of maneuvering weapons managing
resources and executing parries and
being able to cycle back and forth
between these actions in quick
succession makes it feel like you're
fighting is hard to survive as the
gonados are to kill you residential 4
remake is full of smart quality of life
changes that build on what the original
revolutionized and the strongest example
of this is the change in combat
capabilities for Ashley Graham
thankfully Ashley no longer has a health
bar for you to manage with your own
resources instead when Ashley is injured
she'll become incapacitated forcing you
to Juke around enemies in order to get
to her and bring her back to her feet
now the original game sort of
trivialized this aspect of gameplay by
giving you the ability to order Ashley
to hide in a garbage cans while you
dealt with crowds of foes this time
there are still places to hide Ashley
but they are far and fewer between and
that's a welcome change as it makes
protecting her feel much more ingrained
into combat while avoiding the feeling
that she's just an object you have to
keep safe Ashley Graham like Leon is
more fleshed out and believable she
retains that 20 year old sensibility and
react such screaming in horror and shock
at the sight of a parasite erupting from
occultist's head but it's never
overstated residential 4 remake has
struck a nice balance of allowing Leon
and Ashley to communicate from time to
time without overstaying its welcome and
falling into the talks too much
protagonist trend that has become so
prevalent in games in recent years come
on okay I guess this is their idea of a
warm welcome
across the board characters are no
longer the one no plot devices they were
in the original Luis for example is
given a little extra screen time that
better establishes his stakes in the
overarching plot even krauser the 80s
action movie archetypal antagonist that
seemed to walk right out of movies like
Commando feels more rounded things to
further contacts around his stakes and
presence in the narrative albeit still a
Cheesy bad dude some characters however
have been given more flavor than depth
specifically the merchant his iconic
voice has changed but this new version
of The Merchant is Iconic in his own
right and stands as one of the most
memorable characters in the franchise
despite only being a walking and talking
pawn shop don't get yourself killed now
when you're not covering yourself with
the stench of battle as the merchant
likes to say you'll have the opportunity
to go off the beaten path and track down
treasure as well as complete requests
that the merchant has placed around the
environment for you to find some are
scavenger hunts like finding a gold
chicken egg While others and tail
hunting down fiercer and unruly enemies
that require a little backtracking to
get to in exchange for completing these
requests you'll receive spinel gems that
you can trade for treasure maps special
item upgrades and more resources the
request created more incentive to
explore the world and thankfully never
interrupt the flow and pacing of the
game as they often Lead You Back Down
familiar paths with newly gained items
like special keys to unlock cabinets and
devices that hold treasure even as
Leon's Mission takes him to some lesser
visually interesting areas in the latter
chapters of the game a carryover from
the original residual 4 the Remake still
manages to retain a remarkable balance
of action intensity and nail biting
combat scenarios where the original game
started to lose its steam the Remake
manages the keep the experience on track
by considerably changing what I had come
to know so well from the original some
sections of the original game had been
honed trimmed down and reorganized to
better fit into the flow of the game and
also within the environment they take
place in the first encounter with the
blind giant blade-wielding Grotto for
example has been better contextualized
to fit in the torturous depths of the
castle as a result the scene is even
scarier and more stressful than before
it all in general just feels churned up
to 11.
there are also returning boss fights
that I have done a dozen times in the
past some are slightly tweaked While
others have received a welcome more
significant overhaul for nearly all of
them I had a smile plastered across my
face I applauded when I was caught off
guard by new additions and audibly
cheered when I found some of Leon's most
iconic lines were still in the game
alongside new ones on the other hand
some sections of the game have been
caught entirely but it is evident that
has been done with careful consideration
for everything taken out of the game
something new has been introduced to
take its place writing this review has
involved putting the controller down and
stepping away from playing Resident 4
remake and as hyperbolic as a sounds
that is much easier said than done
Resident Evil 4 remake is the
re-envisioning I wanted but also not the
one I expected to get I feared that
messing with the magic of an all-time
classic could spell disaster instead
Resident Evil 4 remake deviates from the
original in many significant ways but
never compromises anything that made it
revolutionary it preserves that
re-contextualizes it and rejuvenates it
this remake stands as a re-envisioning
of its past rather than a replication of
it in doing this it raises the bar for
what a good remake is and at the same
time preserves residual 4's Legacy as a
genre defining experience and one of the
greatest games of all time
foreign